[Music]
with that my name is Joe Young I'm a
product manager in a cloud spanner team
and I have several other speakers with
me uh NRA metal is our senior software
engineering manager she's one of the
people who work the magic behind what
spanner can do I also have Marcus
linebach our chief technologist and it
lead for clout online banking from
Deutsche Bank and of course we have the
illustrious MV Adrian founder and
principal analyst from it Market
strategy you may have known him from
another very popular place that knows a
lot about it
industry now real quick this is our
agenda I'm not going through the bullets
everybody can read here but I do want to
set the stage on how we're going to go
through this by stating why we're here
today this architecture diagram or this
highlight LEL architecture diagram has
spanner in the middle but this is very
common for almost any database
application out there where you have
your key oltp application your
transactional application that's your
most important piece talking to your
database it goes to a backend processing
engine of some sort it goes to storage
and gets data back for you and you
probably have a bunch of other workloads
that could be analytical reports ETL
pushing data out for compliance reasons
and whatnot you probably also want to
feed data to your wonderful AI models so
they actually have useful data and
sensible uh relevant data as you train
these models up so they can give you
great answers so this is the stage where
we're looking at most of you who are
here are probably quite familiar with
this layout you may have some variations
but we're going to get started with
looking at how this works and Marcus is
going to come up here and describe how
Deutsche Bank has actually taken this
and modernize their environment and what
they look forward to uh coming from data
Boos in the future Marcus
thank you Joey so first of all let us
get started and looking into what we are
doing in the German banking industry and
how we're present there right so
Deutsche is present with two distinct
BRS in the German market so we're having
post bank first which is serving the we
call it daily banking activities right
so you're classical you're making a
transaction you're going to an ATM or
you're doing basic investment
functionalities like buying a stock
selling a stock on the other hand we
have Deutsche Bank which is focusing
more on the advisory part complex
Financial products to serve you with
together they're present in over a
thousand branches within Germany what is
compared to the size of our country a
lot so but let's dive into the technical
history of those two PRS right and join
me in 2020 we sat down and looked into
the IT environment setup of both Brands
and they were completely separated they
had separated environment no synergies I
think a classical setup for many large
corporations and if I say environments I
mean data centers so both operated their
own data
centers what is normally happening in
such a situation for large corporations
those corporations go there and think
okay which is the better system which
one do I want to migrate on to and then
you go on a journey you focus on your
migration to get rid of one and focus on
this on the second probably after two
maybe three years you will finish your
journey you've done your migration
what's next oh you focused on migration
let's start with the tech refresh right
so back in 2020 we had been in the
luxury situation of kickstarting our
Google journey together the partnership
and what we said is let's do this
properly let's build up a third platform
from scratch Cloud native where we'll
put our customer data on and that we
will serve our customers from we called
that the customer interaction
platform and the fact that I'm here
today shows that it has worked out and
today we're serving postbank customers
from a completely Cloud native platform
leveraging over 50 Google Cloud native
services this is where we are today as
you can see there there's a road what
we're following on but let's first of
all let's dive a little bit into online
banking as a product
itself
so I said customer interaction platform
platform because it's the single point
of contact for the digital channels
either if you're coming from a mobile
application of us if you're coming from
a third party that is aggregating your
account statements or classically going
to our web page all of those are being
served over that one platform platform
important to say that platform is not
limited for example to our retail
customers it serves all kinds of
customers the small vaa customer our
private accounts but also corporate
accounts now I mentioned we have M
created postbank let's get a little bit
into numbers right and over those
postbank customers more than five
million have activated online banking
they're representing today more than 16
million transactions a
day and something I'm personally really
proud about is if we're looking at on
premise system regulated Industries we
have a lot of applications who are
running quarterly release
Cycles we have brought that down to a
bi-weekly align to our Sprint Cycles
release cycle as part of the migration
you can imagine we had some more
releases going on so already we're above
300 releases on that platform and that
is for the teams for us that's an
important number now let's dive a little
bit into the requirements such a
platform has and if you're looking at
this if you're looking at this the first
thing that comes to your mind as a
customer is your financial overview
right what are you using for your bank
what is the most important topic for you
do I have money on my account how much
do I have is to rent has to rent gone
out stuff like that if you think about
what it comes from a requirement persp
perspective you're talking about
availability you're talking about right
accurate data that you expect from a
bank this is
key on another example in Europe we have
something called instant payment that
means we have milliseconds if you do a
transaction that needs to arrive at the
other bank get deposited there and get
deducted from your account we're talking
milliseconds what is the first reaction
you do after such a transaction for
example you paid for your car you go to
your financial overview and you want to
see that those money left your bank
account right looking at this we call
that a critical workload in our bank and
for this we paired up with
spenner now let's look a little bit into
the requirements towards spenner and the
great team behind what they did I'm not
going through all of them no worries let
me focus on two that are the most
important for us let's talk about the
availability I just mentioned we're
operating spenner in a multi- region
setup and that gives us five nin of
availability if you're into availability
discussion you mean you understand what
it means to have that Baseline of
availability guaranteed by Google that's
a key feature for us to serve our
customers with the to meet their
expectations on the second hand I
mentioned performance right and I
mentioned those 16 million transactions
what I did not mention is that some some
of those customers are handing in
300,000 transaction in one
go just imagine One customer having
300,000 transactions processed and in
the same point in time you want to pay
your car that you just bought would you
be willing to wait until that
transaction comes up you're probably
standing in front of the dealer like I
made that payment it better comes up so
this is what we're using spenner for and
I'm actually quite happy with the
performance and everything we saw
especially with the great team behind
spenner and the the product management
from Google and all the colleagues we're
working on the ground with from
Google something I do like to talk about
is Conant
enhancements as a bank we're coming from
a
legacy and probably all of you are aware
of that product where you had version
six and the project you upgrade was
delayed and then you couldn't and you
stick to that version or there was no
major version coming and then you're in
the situation of being incompliant so we
are really Keen to work with products
where we see the owners of those
products are actually pushing forward
and bringing enhancement and development
in one topic I would like to talk now
about is scaling exactly to say out to
scaling so I mentioned that we M created
post Bank onto our new
platform this was actually the biggest
banking mation
ever done in Europe in
history so we're talking numbers and
we're talking requirements where we
actually shut down the bank so for
customers during that we call it cut
over weekend they couldn't reach the
bank they couldn't transfer money they
couldn't get access to the bank
statement and they couldn't come into a
branch and make something because we
literally migrated everything from
Finance over the CRM we migrated
everything
and when you think about that fact you
want to have that as short as possible
for your customers right so what comes
to your mind first is let's scale our
infrastructure right how can we increase
the processing time and I remember that
moment when we did the analysis and look
what it mean so there were databases
where we thought okay we need to double
them that's something we've seen in our
on premis state as well doubling
infrastructure we looked at some of
those databases and we talked 13 times
the scale we needed for a short period
of time now there's only a limited
amount of manual scaling you want to
do and then we reached out to Google and
said hey how do we do this and Google
actually came back to us and said oh one
engineer did something it's on GitHub
it's open source let's look into that
jointly and one of our really passionate
lead Engineers took that baby I would
say to him and run a PC together with
Google and we do call this production
ready if something can go to production
if we tested it through outly and know
that it's suitable of running our
production load as part of this
production ready State there were
enhancements made and there was that
point when he came back to me and said
Marcus can I roll it out your
production and I was
like are you comfortable with it and he
said I'm comfortable with it Google it
let's do it actually there will be a
blog post about this published by Google
and deut pretty soon because we really
believe in this to be an important
partnership piece and we're proud of it
to show it and we gave it back to the
open source community so you can run on
the same out of scaling than we to run
with our whole environments death U and
production so key point for us and
showing the partnership that Google is
interested
in now let me quickly touch Bas back on
the point point I gave to you from a
road map
perspective because obviously building
up a platform means owning it and
development it further right and you've
seen that we're with post Bank live now
we're looking at our second stage
Deutsche Bank you can imagine those
customers and wealth management
customers having 14 different accounts
different currencies they're demanding
right so we want to do this right and
this is the journey we're on because we
believe in the
platform something we talked a lot on
this conference is AI right what is the
Baseline for AI it's data now having all
of that customer data online related on
a data platform is key for us and
enabling us for new products new
features every new feature development
that we do is done on that new platform
fully Cloud featured by Google obviously
something I'm personally looking forward
to is talking about other Legacy systems
in the bank but this is the journey you
embark on to and we're here after 3 and
1/2
years now let us look at one situation
we're here for data boost right so you
understand that information in
production is very interesting it's a
transaction data of the people they're
doing in combination with something
really important for us the fraud data
behind it because if you want to make a
transaction in online banking you need
to have a second Factor approval to let
that transaction go through right I have
both that data in my production
environment on Google Cloud now I would
like to use that right what we
classically did is we copy over that
data at night when not that much traffic
is on to a data warehouse and then days
or even weeks later you analyze it right
this is where we want to move away from
and for that case we're highly
interested in using our production data
to analyze it on the go and to perform
decisions for fraud detection on that
but without going further into that data
boost topic I would actually hand it
over to the right person to do that Joy
back to you for the explanation of data
boost thanks
Marcus so going back to the slide that
we started with so this is the context
whether you followed the journey that
Deutsche Bank and Marcus let team did
where they modernized by merging systems
from on Prem and moving them onto the
cloud or you already have it sitting in
the cloud the the same scenario exists
you have your most CR latency sensitive
transactional systems and then you have
all of these other really interesting
things and again I I kind of joke a
little bit about the AI part but the
reality is your AI models aren't
terribly useful if they're not trained
with relevant data and those of you who
actually have deployed ml models in
production today give me a show of hands
that you actually have a regularly
scheduled retraining of those
models how many of you do
not okay a couple hon people here very
good so what happens when you need to
run these kinds of workloads and what
happens when you need to run analytics
what happens when some I don't know
colleague attended a conference you know
let's call it some other Tech conference
and they learn how to write squel and
they learn how to write a join and they
have access to two tables that are about
a trillion rows each and they decide I'm
going to run that in your in my
production system because I want to get
smarter decisions anybody experience
that in your production environment only
a handful yall are lucky so I used to
live the DBA life and I I gave that up
because I didn't like my payer going off
at 3: in the morning anymore of course
now we're all in devop so my payer goes
back on again 3:00 in the
morning we looked at that hard in Google
and we decided that you know what
traditional approaches help but they
don't really solve the problems you can
move data using ETL to a separate system
but eventually your ETL becomes another
heavy load against your system you can
also create replicas but that has
additional costs and guess what replicas
require data movement and you pay a cost
you can have resource Governors but
these things also have limitations there
you have to make a decision when an
expensive query or high priority query
comes in which query that is lower
priority will you kick out of the system
which one will you terminate those are
non-trivial decisions because kicking a
database quy out doesn't mean that you
can run it back in the next second it
may actually take you hours of work to
get it back to where it was so we
figured that's probably not a very good
approach and that's where data boost
comes in where if you notice the colors
of the arrows have changed your trans
transactional workloads continue to run
against your original provision spanner
instance that just works nothing changes
but just by doing two things you grant
an I am permission that's on the
security control site and you add one
configuration parameter to your
connection string or to your connection
object literally just these two things
one security setting and one optional
parameter you add to your connection
string spanner will know that these
queries that have these two criteria met
will be automatically rerouted to
completely isolated compute resources as
you can see in a diagram they're
completely separate the compute
resources are isolated and these are
managed by Google you don't have to
worry about provisioning sizing and
whatsoever they're always hot they are
always sitting there waiting for cories
this is not scaling up or down this is
to come through as soon as they come in
there's no latency we service that Cory
immediately we go into Colossus storage
and this is another advantage of spanner
because our computer and storage is
disaggregated this is our architecture
from day one we are able to look into
the actual physical blocks on dis there
are the exact same blocks as your
original spanner instance there's no
replicas here you don't pay for copies
of storage there's no latency involved
in terms of oh let me go create a block
of this so I can read off that all of
this stuff hits you live no Cory latency
we process that get the data back that
we need do a quick check with the
spanner your provision spanner instance
to make sure nothing in memory needs to
be carried over and we send it back to
the client so that way you can literally
go run that big joint with these two
trillion row tables and nobody on the
spanner side would even blink and this
is really really hard to do if you don't
have the same architecture and the same
technology underlying spanner that we
have in today in Google
the one and I should say this and I know
this is engineering crowd but one thing
is important here uh this is also a pay
for the actual quy consumption in terms
of Computer Resources so this is not
something where you over provision and
you sit there it's 80% idle and you get
really busy 20% of the time so I know
Engineers are thinking well what do I
care about pay for you know consumption
it's budget somebody else manages that
but hey imagine right if you save a lot
of money for the company maybe it goes
back into your bonus or at least the
party
fund now we talked about quite a few of
the benefits here I'm not going to go
through each of these in detail they
should be quite obvious but one thing I
do want to call out the last Point here
it does reduce data sprawl because you
need to make fewer copies of your data
direct Federated queries against your
production instance becomes feasible
becomes very practical your pager
doesn't go up at 3:00 in the morning
anymore just because somebody got off of
a conference party and decided to start
running queries against a production
instance that never happens to any of
you I'm sure but that's happened to me
in previous life literally people get
out of a conference after the party and
decided that yeah I only had four drinks
you know at least that I remember let me
go see what's going on in in our
financial
systems one of the things that's really
cool about this is we tested this you
know we went through in queries and
figured that oh let's go try that really
expensive queries that our friendly
analyst run on the left side here you
will see that this is the actual query
run on a production instance of spanner
and you see the CPU Spike and it stays
up there for quite a while those with
really good Vision you'll notice that
some of the spikes actually stay up
there this is CPU running up there for
over several minutes on the right side
the only thing we did Grant permissions
enable that connection string parameter
and you don't see the CPU jump anymore
no code change no schema change it just
works and of course because we are
running on completely separate compute
we are also able to make more aggressive
decisions about parallelization about
how we want to execute and optimize the
query we don't have to worry about
impacting other workloads so this is
another Advantage this is a very modest
8X performance gain we've seen as much
as 100x per gains of course sometimes we
see as little as no gains zero literally
so it really depends on your workload
and the kind of quaries that you're
running no amount of Hardware will solve
really really bad quaries we'll make it
better but we can't really solve bad
queries this is just an example of some
of the workloads are supported on the
bottom right right corner you see we
already have a bunch of isv supporting
it today even though we literally just
announced the product they were so
excited they decided you know what we're
going to get this working even before ug
now all this talk is easy I only have
slides so my colleague nerra is going to
come up here and show you live demo of
how this actually works so this this is
live so everybody you know just send
good thoughts to her and make sure the
demo gods are working in her favor so n
thank
[Applause]
you thank you Jill this is super
exciting hi everybody I am NRA and I
have the awesome job of presenting the
power of datab boost to you all so let's
get
started so in this ever evolving Digital
World gaming is an important experience
in which gamers are spread throughout
the world yet connected an integral part
of this experience is the game Tech that
Fosters Innovation and transformation by
enabling low latency experiences for
gamers in irrespective of their location
irrespective of where they are connected
from so in this demonstration I'll be
using an online multiplayer gaming
scenario in which the gamers are going
to exchange merchandise they're going to
acquire items they're going to loot
items during a session they're going to
use Virtual currency to buy items the
gamers are super excited getting ready
for their next battle acquiring the next
weapon they're looking forward to
acquiring the next Avatar customizing
its appearance so we can see that this
requires slow lency
experiences with transactional
consistency at horizontal scale so this
is where we use cloud spanner as a
backend as the operational
database now while all this is happening
we have the gaming analysts who want to
analyze this data they want to slice and
dice the transactions they want to see
what's happening what merchandise is
being exchanged in these weekend long
long gaming marathons so the way this
has been done typically in the past is
either by overpro visioning the
operational database to avoid impacting
the realtime transactional workload or
maybe by creating copies of data in
replicas read only replicas or maybe by
moving the data out from the operational
database to analytical Warehouse thereby
creating staleness in the pipeline and
this is where steps in data boost as my
colleague Joe explained data boost
harnesses the power of cloud spanners
disaggregated compute and storage
architecture to enable large scale
analytics on operational data with
isolation no impact to your
transactional workloads so with that
let's get started let's switch to the
demo
and while we start against all s advice
I am feeling a little bit courageous and
I'll try to do a live demo so let me
kick off this query and I'll explain
what it does as we go through the
floor so we can see that this is a game
data boost enabled query this is on a
data boost enabled connection I'll walk
through the flow as we go through it so
this is my cloud spanner backend
database instance unicorn game instance
on on which I have a demo game database
I will walk through the schema of the
database this is a typical online gaming
setup where we have the players who are
participating in the online gaming
sessions the player acquires item loot
merchandise we maintain their Ledger we
maintain the trade
orders so now with this let me try to
analyze this data as an analyst through
big
query so to analyze this data from Big
query I'll create Federated query
connections from Big query to my cloud
spanner backend instance this is the
first connection data boost disabled
connection as we can see in this used
datab boost is set to FSE used
parallelism is set to true to harness
the power of batch queries and this is
on the same unicorn game instance and
demo game database that we just saw now
I'll create another inst another
connection which is exactly similar this
is again an external query connection
this is a data boost enabled connection
we can see that the used data boost is
set to true in this one and used
parallelism is also set to true to
harness the power of batch queries again
it's on the same unicorn game instance
and demo game database so now with this
let me try to run some analytical
queries and see the results basically so
this is a query as an analyst I'm
running where I am trying to analyze the
players who run High value transactions
get some statistics on their list price
the number of transactions they took to
achieve that so we can see that I ran
this query at around 2:45 p.m. it ran
roughly for for a period of around 11
minutes and ended at 256 p.m. so now
let's look at the demo game database
instance CPU load at that point and we
can see that the CPU spiked to roughly
around
40% now imagine a scenario where you
have millions of Gamers spread
throughout the world doing these
transactions in real time you have
hundreds of analysts analyzing this data
and the kind of load that's going to put
on the operational database so now let's
try this query through a data boost
enabled connection so this is the query
that I just ran at the beginning of the
demonstration this is the data boost
enabled query and voila we have the
results here already this was a
10-minute query on a data boo disabled
connection and out here we can see it's
the same query that ran at 3:55 p.m. for
a period of roughly around 1 minute and
if I go to the same uh CPU Spike there
and trying to see if there's any CPU
impact there's nothing we can see at
around that point of time so there is no
impact on the operational database as I
ran this query thereby proving the power
of isolation of data boost and another
important thing to note here is this
query ran in 1 minute whereas the data
boost disabled query ran in 11 minutes
so this query got a perf gain of 10x by
moving to data
boost now I'll try to play the role of
an analyst who wants to do slightly more
complex
analysis so for that I'll move on to my
Jupiter notebooks I want to do a cohort
analysis now so as we all know when we
want to do slightly more complex
analysis
doing that in declarative SQL is a
little bit painstaking so I will move on
to imperative python in my Jupiter
notebook and by moving to python also
comes the power of using analytical
Frameworks we can use spark so for this
demo I have used spark as we can see I
have loaded the spark connector to my
backend database here and this is the
same unicorn game instance database the
same demo game and the enabled dat boost
is set to true I'm also going to use an
analytical Frameworks like ppar and
pandas to demonstrate the power of ease
of using them in this demo so for that I
have some utility functions and we can
see that basically for cohort analysis
utility functions I have used pypar I
have also used pandas for this
analysis so moving
further I load my data and this is a
large scale analytical query that I run
basically we can see that this query ran
at around 126 p.m. today it ran roughly
for around 8 minutes it scanned 4
billion
records moving to on to my metrics
Explorer again on the same demo game
database instance and when we can see
the when this large query ran the load
on my operational instance was only 0.6%
thereby approving the power of data
boost basically you can make large scale
analytical queries and it will not
impact your transactional workloads and
these are the results of my cohort
analysis for this cohort analysis I
divided the players into group of three
cohorts and measured their retention
along the weeks as the gaming session
progressed so for the first week we see
53% of the players remained in the
second week 9% in the uh basically week
after that and 9% uh further down 9% in
the last week and then we have the
retention of players across the other
two weeks so the nut nutshell in a
nutshell we can see with this demo that
using data boost it's you get true
isolation for your transactional
workloads you get the benefit of
performance depending upon your query
shapes and how easy and simple it is to
use data boost you can use it from Big
query you can use it from analytical
Frameworks like spar you can use it from
data processing applications like data
flow you can use it from client
applications and it'll give the ability
to run large scale ad hoc analysis with
true isolation so thank you all with
this I'll hand over to M who's going to
talk to us about what data boost means
for Next Generation data
management thank you am I on yeah okay
so
can I have the slides all right so some
of you have the luxury of being able to
go to whoever writes the checks for the
hardware and software you use and show
them a demo like that and have them
understand of it most of us don't and so
they bring in people like me industry
analysts who say well what what does all
this mean to you um that's my theme here
it's the bigger picture how does this
stuff fit in we're talking about the
next generation of data management
preparation meets opportunity and
transforms how you do what you do what
it costs you to get it done what kind of
results you
have so consider the basics you know Joe
laid this out very nicely it would be
nice to have unlimited data scale very
few of us can assert that we have that
but you know the way that management
sees this is I'm in the cloud right
isn't that why I went there I've got
unlimited data scale um yeah of course
costs may be unlimited too and they're
less eager to hear that story so to the
point of should I make multiple replicas
of this in order to get the performance
I want um yeah that sounds great until
you have to write the
check similarly I have unlimited compute
scale don't I up in the cloud yes but do
I have access to it and even if I have
it is the storage of this system
prepared to handle multiple different
highlevel compute loads being thrown at
it at the same time that's what we call
workload management most systems do not
do this gracefully
today so if we turn people loose and
only drive our plans on the basis of
what we think we need and the assumption
that we can do anything we want in the
cloud we're going to have a rather large
curve of costs
but we're also going to have to deal
with security
issues and we're going to have a great
deal of semantic confusion because
different people looking at the same
data may think it means entirely
different things so we need to be able
to manage this in a uniform governed
way in order to move to a a world that's
as happy as the one you just
saw we need to handle a number of things
and all of these things need to be
handled in the cont text of today's
environments which have you can think of
it as a ceiling we can push this so far
right
so whatever we deploy needs to be
intelligent it needs to know how to use
the available resources it needs to
be observability
enabled so that if I can put in
something that manages the operation of
this system and doesn't require me to
wake Joe up at 3: in the morning by
ringing his pager I have to have
observability on this system this system
has to be self-reporting and it has to
send those reports to something that can
do something about what it's
learning that's governance the system
has to be governed and it doesn't just
mean I know lineage it doesn't just mean
I know the users and what they're
allowed to do means the operation of the
system itself needs to be
I have a ceiling if I've got 40% of my
CPU being utilized and you need to pay
for your car as Marcus described you
don't want to wait while those other
jobs run and so I'd like to have that
unlimited scale I want that scale to be
there when I need it and I don't want to
have to stop to make it available or
Paige Joe to make it available for me
right I want that to be autonomous I
want the system to take what it it needs
to meet my requirements when the system
needs them and I need all of this to be
integrated I don't want this this to
happen in four different consoles I
don't want multiple players who have to
set this up I'd like to set two
parameters and just have it run the way
you saw earlier in fact you know in a
perfect world I'd like not to have to
set those parameters oh let the system
do it but I know you're getting to that
um and finally what I want is for that
operating system then to be optimized
for me not just in terms of its
performance but also in terms of how I
pay for it when I pay for it even
whether I pay for it I don't want to pay
for what I'm not using and that's what
overr provisioning is all about right so
I like to say to people if necessity is
the mother's of is the mother of
invention choices are its children when
I build systems out of necessity I have
to make a lot of choices and some of
them are very un
comfortable and until now the choice of
can I scale the way we're talking about
was a simple one let's spend a whole
bunch of money and buy a lot of capacity
that most of the time is going to go
unused that's not an acceptable answer
that's not the choice we want to make
we've got a ceiling we don't want to
have to figure out how to live within it
so
today at the end of let's call it the
first era of cloud data management as we
move into the next we have a lot of
those choices to make how many of us how
many of you guys thought when we moveed
to the cloud everything would be simple
in terms of configuration and yeah thank
you Marcus you know better um ever see
how many instance types there
are I I you know I don't consider that
particularly simple um it gives us
choices though and those choices are
important when I need a certain thing I
want an instance that'll do it for me
ideally though if I have the autonomy
I'm talking about the system will do
that for me in fact it'll because it's
observability enabled look at the
workload and it'll say well what this
thing needs is some tpus I'm running a
model let's give it the right kind of
processor to run that model on um what
other kinds of choices well what format
do I want the data to be
in do I accept the one it's already in
can I operate against that format or do
I need to make another copy of it
somewhere else in a more optimized form
to run it that way I have a very simple
rule for copies of data you should have
as many copies of the data as you
need and not one
more so the system will tell you how
many copies you need if it can handle it
in the formats it it's already in but
you may have other reasons that drive
that choice it might be the language
you're using the fact that it's a legacy
system that can easily be changed well
there's more choices here but I don't
know how much time we have left Joe I'm
I'm I'm going to try to be I'm going to
be R tried oh I got six minutes I didn't
see I had a clock there thank you all
right so let's talk about one or two
more of them because they're
important what about the cost of moving
data around the system import export
okay duplication refresh in a system
that has massive amounts of data like a
gaming system um how much do I care
about the behavior of the users 6 months
ago or the behavior of the users 3
months ago or the behavior of the users
yesterday in the in the scenario that
you saw demonstrated what I really want
to know is what users are doing right
now and maybe what they've been doing
for the last 24 hours but most of that
historical understanding is probably
embedded in some kind of a model that
I'm using to make decisions and choices
and then last and perhaps most
important yes we're in the cloud yes we
have capacity for data yes we have
capacity for compute but we also have
mixed workloads we got transactions
going on at the same time as analytics
and is it really that simple we're in
the cloud so we can do it now no it's
not we need a system that can
effectively
leverage the capabilities that the cloud
provides us to run mixed
workloads even if the ceiling is
gone
so when I say we're moving from one ear
of the cloud we are in fact doing just
that because with this sort of
autonomous autonomous sorry
intelligent
self-configuring observability enabled
kind of a system we can quote one of my
favorite Paul Simon songs one man's
ceiling is another man's
floor we can start wherever we want and
we can go as high as we need to go
because the system will gracefully do do
it for us um this is
new this is very new as an industry
analyst I've been following workload
management enabled database systems for
a very very long time they all work with
ceilings and they all work by swapping a
little bit of work out of this workload
for that other workload in order to try
to do as graceful a job of degrading
performance when something else enters
the room as they can this is different
it's a floor now we can start wherever
we want and we can get to wherever we
want on the basis of a system that knows
how to do it for us automatically it's
very exciting and I'm very happy to be
here to talk to you about it Joe back to
[Applause]
you thank you and you want uh no we're
good I think we you can hang on just for
just one minute we literally have our
last slide and we get one our Q&A so
folks who have questions feel free to uh
gather around the microphone but really
just a quick summary of what we've
covered I know we walk through a lot of
different concepts really quickly but
the whole idea is regardless of where
you're at today or how you got to the
cloud or you're just starting out in the
cloud uh this is actually a proven
approach and there are a lot of folks in
the Google Cloud world that can help you
there and make sure you learn from our
experiences make learn from folks like
Marcus experiences and don't have to
stumble through on your own the other
thing really is and I'm not going to go
through all of these details but the key
takeaway here is you don't have to worry
about sharing data broadly just because
somebody might run a workload that will
wake you up in the morning I joke about
the 3:00 a.m. pager calls but those
aren't the worst because I I get to do a
lot of things at 3:00 a.m. I'm usually
up anyway the worst are the ones that
happen at 10:00 on a Monday morning
because that's when things are really
really busy and somebody decides to go
run that trillin row table joint that's
when you really don't want the page to
go off so with data boo we believe we've
made that possible but I invite you to
try and either uh prove it for yourself
or if it didn't work for you let us know
we want to know what it is and we will
fix that thank you very much for hanging
around and listening to us if you have
questions we'll be hanging out right
outside here thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you